you have people like andrew yang
whatever you think about him just more
honest he he just like says whatever the
hell
uh comes to mind by the way he's running
for new york
mayor there we go do you have opinions
yeah it's no good i like andrew yang and
it's no good
i i'll be honest with you i'm a lifelong
new yorker i mean i'm a new yorker
well you're in new york so nothing's
good well something is good
okay and talking on let's be honest
about new york
it's a very socially liberal place it is
the head of the snake
new york is the country if new york when
new york's not doing good countries not
doing good
um it's the most important city dc new
york
it's really rome be honest it's it's uh
maybe i'm biased i don't know
no we just new yorkers we walk around
everywhere we go this is just like new
york but not new york
it's um but and new york needs
and i'm a guy who leans left uh you know
i just i'd lean left and that's just
what it is
a dictator is that where you're going no
we don't like this
we need it's a money town let's be come
on man
i mean new york is a money town and uh
wall street and then when aoc and her
cronies
um at the local level rejected that
amazon thing you're going like
what do you think makes cities and what
what what's going to create jobs in the
21st century what do we need
more nail salons more pizza places i
mean we're living in the tech revolution
and
you know whatever your opinions are
about jeff bezos
that's the world tech and they wants to
come here
of course you give them tax breaks
that's why any companies go anywhere
she's so [ __ ] utopian and that that
progressive wing is so utopian
and that always ends in disaster because
it's not rooted in reality it doesn't
accept the reality that people are
self-interested now they're going to do
this 14
15 tax hike on people making a million
dollars more in new york city a million
dollars not that much
so people are going to flee new york the
tax base is going to flee
new york's going to follow [ __ ] like it
did before so you're saying it basically
needs
a more capitalist front like
capitalistic type of thinker that
bloomberg
giuliani when he was still sane and his
hair wasn't melting off his face
prosecutor you need to talk i mean i
don't know what's happened that guy's
lost it
but it's fun yeah it's fun to watch yeah
it's fun to watch him be just like uh
trump's lacking like yeah boy whatever
you want boss i'll just say whatever you
want boys
uh but new york is a money town that
needs a money guy and sort of more
of a republican i have to say on the
local level as more of a guy who leans
left i'll just be honest
it it's a tough city that needs a tough
mayor not some guy who's going like i
understand we all need free money
you know andrew yang i think is right in
the big picture because all the
real jobs are somewhere else you look at
those asian cities you go like oh
that's what our cities used to look like
at the industrial revolution you know
there was like there was jobs and people
were making things here and
now you look at those cities in asia and
you're going like wow and then you go to
detroit and you're like
yeah we're done you go to cleveland you
go we we're done
so i don't actually it's funny the the
reason i really like andrew yang is
i've learned a lot every time he talks
like it's not his opinions
he's just giving a lot of data yeah like
information which i
just start a podcast don't run for mayor
well yeah that's true he already has a
podcast i think
yang speaks
you